[Musique]
une épicière vraiment pas comme les
autres
non
pour la petite histoire précisant
qu'elle officiait à avignon dans un
quartier qui a vu naître mireille
mathieu et qui possède d'ailleurs un nom
prédestiné la croix des oiseaux
[Musique]
madame jeannine d'arranger ne roule pas
des romances comme la synthèse
plus prosaïquement elle siffle elle
siffle tous les dimanches en sa qualité
d'arbitré officiel de dc de football du
rhône
[Musique]
mais si vous êtes responsable de vos
équipes
vous savez qu'à la moindre incartade
soit un avertissement soit l'expulsion
et que sur le terrain tout un état en
forme je suis un arbitre
[Musique]
vous avez six enfants certains d'entre
eux sont mariés comment des enfants juge
utile leur maman arbitre survol belle et
grande très bien mais la petite finale
le point sur tout à la rigolade
elle aime ça me suis tous les dimanches
sur les stades des joueurs en tout cas
ne vous prennent pas la rigolade au
départ si au départ quand ils voient une
voir il va y voit une femme ça les fait
rire mais retrait non
[Musique]
une femme qui mate le mot n'est pas trop
fort 22 hommes sur le terrain commence
comporte-t-elle à la maison sk la
tendance à porter le pantalon droit ce
cas d'égalité des sexes devrait en tout
cas réjouir
madame françoise giroud secrétaire
d'état à la condition féminine
[Musique]